fighting between government forces and
the m23 rebel group has sent thousands
of people on the run in eastern
democratic republic of congo it's not
the first time
we were just told that m23 have come
back again they emerged from the forest
to attack the congolese government at
the moment we are just seeing government
forces driving up and down the road but
we don't have a solution yet
nine years ago m23's fighters took
control of swathes of territory along
the border with neighbouring rwanda
it's widely believed to be a proxy of
rwanda's government although rwanda
denies it
congo's army blames rwanda for the
recent attacks which started on tuesday
congolese officers paraded these two
prisoners in front of journalists in the
city of gomer and said they were rwandan
soldiers fighting for the armed group
the m23 supported by the rwanda defence
forces has carried out incursions and
attacks on jrc military positions in
chanzu and rignoni in rochiro territory
m23's fighters have taken control of
some villages near the border with
uganda
the group denies having foreign support
the m23 rebellion is a congolese
movement and doesn't benefit support
from any neighboring country the
accusations of the drc is to just cover
their incapacity on the ground as for
the current ongoing fighting we are
defending ourselves against the
different attacks that we have been
facing from the government army since
many days
thousands of people have crossed the
border into uganda to get away from the
fighting uganda and rwanda have both
been accused of meddling in eastern
congo and displacing people ever since
they invaded in the 1990s
congo has one of the world's largest un
peacekeeping missions
it's rarely effective at stopping
violence but in 2014 it helped defeat
m23 with a strengthened mandate and
extra troops sent from tanzania malawi
in south africa
the defeat was a high point for congo's
army too his soldiers flushed out the
rebel group with international support
now it's short of resources and
struggling to control parts of the east
people here waiting to see how far m23
will go this time and if the congolese
army can stop them
malcolm webb al jazeera